happening tonight a vigil for the
victims of another recent mass shooting
our local lgbtqia plus advocacy Advocacy
Center remembering those lost in
Colorado Springs over the weekend
Madison Kimbrough live there tonight to
give us a Look Madison
yeah earlier tonight there were candles
everywhere the stage was set in a Podium
where people spoke to talk about enough
is enough as hate crimes Across the
Nation need to stop
in a world where we should all have the
right to be anything why is it so hard
for people to just let us be ourselves
emotions ran high as people gathered at
the center to honor the lives lost in
the Colorado Springs nightclub shooting
last Saturday five people died and 17
more were injured the center which is a
community-based organization
specifically for those who identify as
lgbtqia plus hosted the candlelight
vigil a moment of silence was held for
each victim killed a candle lit for each
one we come together because we know
that an attack on any individual that
identifies as lgbtqia plus is indicative
of the hate or community experiences
every day and we have to stand United
with our friends in Colorado Springs and
County officials who showed up making it
known that they are allies within the
community and proud of the work the
center continues to do as a Clark County
Commissioner I want to make sure that we
understand
that the county stands with the lgbtq
community
um in times of difficulty like today it
feels like yesterday that we were all
here for support of those who died at
the Pulse Nightclub shooting Orlando
this Center is a Beacon of Hope for our
lgbtqia community as a mental health
therapist and I am a trustee on the
school board but I'm here as an
individual I counsel Children and
adolescents that are coming out to their
families that don't have a place to go
and to speak
about a hundred people attended this
tonight's vigil and it lasted for about
an hour reporting live here at the
center on Maryland Parkway Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now